okay we gotta talk about how funny it is
that sand land keeps completely owning
Dragon Ball fans lately like it's almost
as if they're toying with us on purpose
Dragon Ball super return announcement
announcement instead potential
announcement on National Goku day get
wrecked fools here's sandland kokute
potential Budokai Tenkaichi 4 gameplay
at The Game Awards April fools you're
getting sand land the video game now
don't get me wrong these sandland
projects all seem pretty cool but like
you gotta admit it's almost like they're
torturing us on purpose perhaps we most
simply accept that sand land is King now
sand land clear sweep sandland is now
more iconic than Super Saiyan